اعتراف صريح خرج هذه المره وان كان مسربا
من داخل اروقه النظام الايراني يقر بان
الاحتجاجات شلت النظام بعكس ما كان متوقعا
وفق تسجيلات لمسؤول ايراني تم تسريبها
فبعد ان كانت اصابع الاتهام تتوجه دائما
الى الخارج والترويج لمؤامرات خارجيه
اعترف المسؤول بوجود ما سماها مساوئ
داخليه فضلا عن مشاكل اقتصاديه كلها
تراكمات وتسببت بتغذيه الاحتجاجات عقب
وفاه سامي المسؤول الايراني كشف نوايا
النظام وخطته القادمه تجاه المحتاجين
متحدثا عن ان السلطات ستلجا الى استخدام
مزيد من القوه لاحتواء المتظاهرين واحتواء
الاحتجاجات التي دخلت اسبوع التاسع
[موسيقى]
اه تمام تمام
ورقم هذه الخطه القمعيه الجديده الا ان
المسؤول الايراني استبعد انهاء الاحتجاجات
بكبسه زر وفقه ووصفه داعيا السلطات الى حل
المشاكل صوره الانتعاش لدى النظام المسؤول
وصفا النظام بانه عانى من شلل تحليلي
بدايه الاحتجاجات مشيرا في التسجيل الصوتي
المسرب ان رقعه الاحتجاجات اتسعت تزامنا
مع فتح الجامعات هذا ليس كل شيء في
التسريع الذي يعترف المسؤول الاستخبارات
الايرانيه بان الكثير من قتل الاحتجاجات
ابرياء كما كشف عن اعداد تقديريه
للمعتقلين من الاحتجاجات قائلا انها بلغت
15,000 شخص 70% منهم تتراوح اعمارهم بين
17 عاما و20 عاما و خلال تسجيله المسرب
هذا حذر المسؤول الايراني من ان بلاده
ستشهد اغتيالات وانفجارات مجهوله دون ان
يقدم تفصيل عن طبيعه او زمن هذه
الانفجارات والاغتهالات